you can buy five of AMD's new thread
route 32 core CPUs and pocket thousand
dollars for the same price of intel's
flagship 20-acre Seaview which not only
has less course but lower clock speeds
[Music]
welcome to Haris hobbies so first of all
this is a leak but it's coming from a
very reputable source video cars who
have gotten a lot of things right in the
past and honestly I think we all
expected this type of pricing from AMD
for their new thread Ripper two CPUs and
so while this is just a leak and not
official it really kind of is now there
may be some small clock speed variations
by a couple of yorkers and the price may
be a couple of hundred dollars more
maybe up to two thousand dollars but the
main principle still remains you can get
multiple of these better CPUs from AMD
instead of just one single worst view
from Intel this type of disparity should
never exist period you shouldn't even be
able to get to better CPUs for the price
of one not to mention multiple and so
this really shows how into husband
screen has over for the last many years
and it is nice that AMD is finally
clearing yourself and here's what they
are offering starting off with the
twenty nine twenty X which is a twelve
core twenty four thread CPU with a base
clock of 3.5 meters and a max turbo
clock of four point three D Gerdes and a
TDP of 180 watts and a price of six
hundred and fifty dollars now it is a
pretty much identical with the 1920 X
except for has a point three gigahertz
faster turbo speed and it's coming in at
one hundred and fifty dollars cheaper on
release next up is the 2950 X which says
64 CPU and 32 threads with the base
clock of 3.5 years and a max turbo clock
of 4.4 viewers coming in at 180 watts
with the TDP and $900 now again this is
pretty much identical with the past
generation 1950 X with its base being
point 1 gear is faster and its boost
being point four degrees faster so
pretty much identical and right now
you can actually get a 1950 ex on you
egg for 779 dollars so this is nothing
groundbreaking but it is a nice little
upgrade next up is the 2970 WX this CPU
is supposed to have 24 cores 48 threads
with a base clock of 3.0 gigahertz and a
max travel is frequency of 4.2 birds it
is supposed to consume 250 watts and it
come in at a price of $1,300 now if you
take a look at Intel's equivalent in
terms of course its base frequency is
actually 0.5 gigahertz lower and whose
frequency is 2.9 gigahertz lower yet it
costs almost five times more at five
thousand dollars finally is the twenty
nine ninety WX with 32 cores and 64
threads with the base clock of 3.0 beers
and a magic treble frequency of the 4.2
gears with the TDP of 250 watts coming
in at 1800 dollars you can't even get
Intel CPU with this amount of course the
clothes that you can get is a 28 core
CPU and that comes in at ten thousand
dollars and what's nice is that it
infinity fabric technology from AMD is
really showing here this AMD is able to
offer us scalable prices for example we
can get 12 cores for $650 and 24 cores
for $1,300 and we can get 16 cores for
932 cores for 1,800 so that's really
nice that AMD is able to offer such
lenient pricing with their high core
consuit peers as well so in the end this
really just shows how badly we've been
ripped off by Intel based such huge
strides the CPU market are just not
possible for AMD in just a couple of
years so obviously this type of
technology was not that hard to tame and
Intel was just holding it back from us
and offering us really overpriced CPUs
instead --into has been working on CPUs
for many years and there are much more
well-established than AMD so if AMD is
able to do it Intel is able to do it
better and Intuit has just been choosing
not to do it after all it is really just
an in silicon and it just comes down to
the development costs so really the
truth is that intel has not just been
ripping yourself they have been like
trolling us even now there are flagships
79-80 XE costs 18 $79 and only has 18
course you can almost get double the
amount of course for a lower price from
AMD these types of price advancements
don't just happen overnight now there is
no reason to be mad at Intel because
they simply had a monopoly and took
advantage of it we should simply be
grateful that Amy's bringing in such
great competition and hopeful that Intel
will be more competitive in the future
and hopefully we will have two great
options to choose from in the very
imminent future but that's all I have
for you guys system how do you guys feel
about the CPU market right now make sure
comment down below what you guys think
because I do it all my comments I'm
curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys liked it and make sure drop a
like and consider subscribing if you
would like to see more videos just like
this one but until then I'm hari I'll
catch you guys on the next one
[Music]